tonight on abc it's a big one for
chandelier drama station 19 and grey's
anatomy but
the big question for every single grace
fans continues to be
will this season be the last
are you hoping they'll carry on after
season 17.
it will be interesting to see what
happens in the next few months
patrick dempsey gave a subtle hint and
now gray's showrunner krista vernoff
just revealed she's planning a season 17
ender that could function as either a
season finale
or a series finale sources tell the
hollywood reporter ellen pompeo has been
in negotiations for months with abc
she's the highest paid woman on network
tv making 20 million a year
and her contracts up at the end of the
season i miss you
i know but tonight grace returns with a
station 19 crossover
the episode comes after a super long
12-week hiatus
some think we might see mcdreamy and
meredith finally meet on that beach
so nice to see everybody and to work
with ellen again
you know the response has been very
positive so that's really rewarding
did you know there's more mick dreamy to
come i know that america loves it
and i know that they'd be smart to get
as much in there as possible
with 10 episodes left this season
there's still lots to look forward to
but
debbie allen almost ruined a big star's
return
with this accidental tick-tock reveal if
i didn't see you in my video
some think that voice belongs to ellen's
dead tv sister kyler lee
others say it's katherine heigl and if
they'll go back
to that show with all these other cameos
happening i would never say never but
it's
it's not likely i'm sorry is there a
more shocking thing coming up than
patrick dempsey's return
oh there is okay wow it's all relative
for who you
who you're invested in but i yeah yeah
i'd say so i think it's sandro
somebody satan